this is Apple's new iMac it looks just
like last year's iMac there's some big
internal upgrades like Intel's new
skylake processors and the cheaper
fusion drive hybrid storage for
everybody but that's all just Moore's
law stuff this is the same iMac that
gets a little bit better and a little
bit faster
year after year after year there is one
big new feature but you can't see it we
have these fancy cameras and cool video
streaming technology but the only way to
see the IMAX new display is to see the
IMAX news display that's because the
whole upgrade here is a new color gamut
basically the way it works is that your
eyes can see this incredibly wide range
of colors and most displays can only see
a tiny sliver of that this display is
based on a standard called p3 which
widens that a little bit it means that
instead of seeing one shade of red where
there should be ten Kasese maybe three
that means colors are more accurate and
more lifelike and that you get to see
more details in everything it's not a
huge change and it won't matter to most
people but you should go look at it it's
really nice right now though the best
reason to buy an iMac if you're in the
market is that the 5k display that Apple
launched last year on a super high-end
model is now available on all of the 27h
imax that means you can get this screen
for $1,800 there's also the smaller 21.5
inch model which now at the highest end
has a 4k screen and that one goes for
1499 dollars seriously these screens are
awesome but the iMac is still kind of a
niche product it's perfect for certain
people with certain needs and probably
total overkill for everybody else what's
more interesting for most people are
these new accessories there's a new
keyboard called the magic keyboard
there's a Magic Trackpad 2 and a Magic
Mouse - the keyboard is the biggest
difference
it's way thinner because Apple didn't
have to put a double-a battery inside
that also mean they had to redesign the
scissor mechanism on the keys so when
you type it's a little shallower and it
doesn't click quite the way the old
Apple keyboard used to it
but it still feels pretty good the Magic
Trackpad is basically the same as the
trackpad on the new Mac
pros including the fact that it has
forced touch which lets you press extra
hard to do hidden things on the back
it's white it's thin and it fits
perfectly next to the magic keyboard
then there's a Magic Mouse which is
still just a magic Mouse one other cool
thing all three of these charged via
their lightning ports if you plug it in
for just a couple of hours it will last
more than a month and they all pair to
your computer using the same lightning
port just plug it in for a couple of
seconds then pull it out and use it just
like you would any other wireless
accessory these accessories are actually
much more important than the new iMac at
least until these P three screens become
much more prevalent and they're very
much a part of this futuristic idea
Apple has about how we're going to
interact with our computers even the
ones that don't have screens that look
this good